لذلك يعتبر التاسع من مايو يومًا مهمًا للغاية بالنسبة
لروسيا ، يُعرف باسم يوم النصر ، فهو
يحتفل باليوم الذي
هزمت فيه القوات الروسية
النازيين والمسؤولين الأمريكيين والمسؤولين الغربيين الذين
اعتقدوا منذ فترة طويلة أن التاسع من مايو قد يكون
يومًا يعلن فيه الرئيس الروسي
إما  نوع من الانتصار الكبير في
أوكرانيا أو تصعيد كبير
وهم يتقدمون في سيناريو واحد
وهو أنه أعلن الحرب رسميًا في ذلك
اليوم مما سيسمح له بعد ذلك
بتعبئة قوات الاحتياط ، حيث عانت القوات الروسية
في شرق أوكرانيا
من  النقص الهائل في القوى العاملة ،
لذلك سيسمح هذا
للرئيس بتجنيد المزيد من القوات بشكل أساسي
في القتال وتعبئة
عامة السكان هناك في روسيا ،
وهذا بالطبع أيضًا يوم رئيسي
للدعاية حتى يتمكنوا أيضًا من تحفيز
الرأي العام للحرب من خلال
الإعلان رسميًا فعليًا  أنهم
يشنون حربًا ضد النازيين في
أوكرانيا بالطبع هذه كذبة
سمعناها من روسيا تقول مرارًا وتكرارًا
إنهم يخوضون عملية عسكرية خاصة
ضد النازية في أوكرانيا ،
لذا قد تكون هذه لحظة ينتهز فيها فلاديمير
بوتين هذا النوع من أه
وتنتهز هذه الفرصة أه لتعلن
حربًا رسمية على أوكرانيا نوعًا من تعبئة
أه قوات الاحتياط هناك  الذي
يحتاجه من أجل
خوض هذه الحرب بنجاح
في شرق أوكرانيا الآن هناك
عدد من السيناريوهات الأخرى بما في ذلك
أنه يمكنه ضم مناطق معينة في
شرق أوكرانيا بما في ذلك
منطقتي لوهانسك ودونيتسك ،
ولكن حتى الآن ما نراقبه نحن والمسؤولون الغربيون
حقًا هنا  هو ذلك
الإعلان الرسمي للحرب الذي يمكن أن يكون
مهمًا جدًا لكريستين